[Musique]
aujourd'hui monsieur c'est à vous katia
bonjour amical bonjour nicolas dupont
aignan on vient de parler de la position
de marion maréchal-le pen sur les vga la
proposer à la provoqué une controverse
au sein même du front national avec sa
tante marine le pen marine le pen
hier justement a tenté un peu de se
relancer de sortir de ces sujets en
proposant une proposition choc qui est
de restreindre l'accès à l'école
gratuite aux enfants d'étrangers
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
proposition à commenter les propositions
de madame le pen je suis candidat à la
présidence de la république ça ne
m'intéresse pas est ce que c'est une se
faisait sécher sont gérés de se relancer
je vis un peu souvent chez vous alors à
la porte posez moi des questions sur mon
projet pourquoi imposer ses conditions
est ce que c'est est-ce que vous avez
des régions de favorables j'ai un projet
différent voilà d'accord est ce que vous
n'avez pas là justement la sensation
d'être un peu coincé entre françois
fillon et marine le pen
c'est absurde si vous étiez venu à mon
meeting on l'a suivi
vous l'avez suivi vous auriez vu la
force des gens leurs convictions meeting
interactive dans toute la france nous
sommes des gaullistes
nous croyons en l'effort collectif de la
france son indépendance et en même temps
le partage social est plus que jamais
avec le programme de françois fillon
il y à la place au contraire pour une
alternative politique ce que j'appelle
l'autre politique serait je me suis
engagé auprès de philippe séguin il ya
20 ans oh c'était le rassemblement des
jeunes au rassemblement pour l'autre
politique s'était déjà je me souviens
phillips et leurs revenus la pluie le
junior coûts qui avait écrit une tribune
magnifique dans le figaro où dans le
monde c'était tellement si je peux finir
ma phrase sur le munich social munich
social c'étaient des paroles très fortes
à l'égard de balladur et bien ironie du
sort va temps après on n'a pas changé
françois fillon c'est un munich social
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire c'est une
politique déflationniste de matraquage
fiscal qui va tuer l'entreprise sous
prétexte de l'aider il va la tuer c'est
le chemin de la grèce de la déflation
cumulative qui aboutit à en fin de
compte à des déficits plus important
vous avez peut-être suivant meeting vous
avez vu que je propose un programme
économique très original
je veux baisser massivement les charges
uniquement sur les entreprises qui
produisent en france les pme en divisant
par deux l'impôt sur les sociétés mais
uniquement celle qui produit sur le sol
français
j'en ai marre des baisses de charges
pour des entreprises qui délocalisent
mais je finis juste et je veux relancer
le pouvoir d'achat en récupérant
l'argent qu'on verse à bruxelles et le
donner aux retraités avec moi 6 millions
de retraités auront 100 euros de plus
par mois sans que ça coûte un centime à
l'état
comment les 8 milliards qu'on donne à
bruxelles pour financer nos concurrents
qui viennent nous piquer nos emplois eh
bien je les rends retraités français
pour qui vivre dans la dignité et je
relance le pouvoir d'achat je relance
l'économie locale entend bien faire ça
c'est un changement majeur non alors
quand ça vaut bien plus que les
propositions de x ou y eu pour faire du
buzz donc il me faisait des propositions
nantes on attend vos propositions mais
sur votre est fondamentale on entend vos
propositions mais sur votre créneau mais
vous et sur votre façon de présenter
françois fillon comme le candidat de
l'ultralibéralisme vous avez les mêmes
mots que marine le pen et alors ce n'est
parlé des blagues à porte pour se
démarquer mais pourquoi c'est drôle mais
je vous en veux pas la politique c'est
pas des créneaux on n'est pas dans des
marques de yaourt
fondée dans l'avenir de la france moi je
vous dis une chose si françois fillon ou
manuel valls sont élus on en reprend
repas pour cinq ans d'une politique susi
d'air de régression sociale et de déclin
économique imposé par l'union européenne
ça veut dire que je dis aux français qui
me regardent
faites gaffe si vous partez pour cinq
ans fera pas bien vous plaindre et je
suis le seul à proposer une politique
alternative sérieuse sans les excès du
front national ou de monsieur mélenchon
ya trois anti système en france réelle
il ya monsieur mélenchon il ya madame le
pen et ya moi je suis moins connus que
les autres mais j'ai le programme le
plus sérieux avec des gens équilibrés
qui sont élus localement et je défends
une autre politique constate une folle
et un quadrillage 20 du territoire pensé
que vous pouvez batman oui oui je suis
convaincu que les médias et le petit
système politique français ps
républicain
adore madame le pen en fait parce que ça
leur permet au dernier moment de
toujours gagner
on l'a vu au moment des régionales et je
pense que le jour où il ya un
patriotisme serein sérieux avec des gens
équilibrés qui ont des propositions
concrètes qui émergent
eh bien les français se diront enfin on
peut se débarrasser de ceux qui nous
font du mal et on va pas continuer
éternellement voter pour des gens qui
font du bien vous pensez en pour autant
passer au front national
vous dites oui je suis le vote utile
parce que c'est la première alternative
patriotique sérieuse aux médias russes
vous serez au second tour face à un
candidat mais le système entre
guillemets je vais me battre pour être
second tour et je répète à tous les
français une rencontre arrêtez de voter
pour des gens qui vous font du mal ça
fait 30 ans que vous voter pour des gens
qui vous font du mal quand est ce que
vous allez arrêter et je vous propose un
projet qui va nous redonner de
l'espérance
j'ai un programme par exemple s'ils ont
peut-être que les gens regardent le psy
qui est derrière vous avec qui vous
pouvez gouverner ce we à basic mais
beaucoup mieux avec qui beaucoup mieux
que ceux qui ont gouverné puis vint
encore gouverneur et louis avec des élus
locaux qui sont réélus c'est curieux eux
à 80 % des voix régulièrement fait des
groupes parlementaires et à la rêverie
seront élues députées le projet pak a
besoin de ménager besoin de changer un
peu tout ce qui succède et conques ont
ruiné le pays qui se révoltent premier
ministre si je vous ai dit vers
éloquence donnant du fil avait déjà
anticipé
vous avez choisi a l'embarras du choix
une minute la dernière question une
actualité de la semaine c'est le
référendum italien porté par matteo
renzi qui a été rejetée vous avez
félicité beppe grillo mon ami c'est
votre ami est ce qu il ferait un bon
premier ministre pour l'italie oui et je
serais heureux savez il ya une photo
amusante et prémonitoire
je pense nous étions à bruxelles avec
beppe grillo avec nigel farrage ya
quelques années on nous regardait de
haut et il ya cette photo et je pense
que les peuples européens n'en peuvent
plus d'une mauvaise europe qui nous tue
et quand on voit les américains qui
choisissent leur destin qui vont
relancer leur économie qui vont protéger
vis-à-vis de la chine et nous on se vend
à la chine on se vend mais on va arrêter
de vendre notre pays par morceaux et il
va falloir en finir avec cette mauvaise
europe en revanche c'est le donald trump
izaguirre et ans
oui tout à fait ça veut dire qu'il va
falloir reconstruire une europe parce
que moi je veux pas le fric site
je veut renégocier les traités je veux
des baux traiter ce qu'on a fait avec
airbus
on peut le faire pour la lutte contre le
cancer l'europe des nations et des
projets projet a peu de pays
et là vous ferez mais le rock